Welcome back everyone this is good to be my
Rick and Morty season five episode four video
there were so many crazy references in Easter
eggs during the episode will break it all down
If you're brand-new to the channel, be sure
to subscribe to get all the episodes were
doing a giveaway for Rick and Morty merge
all you have to do to enter is be subscriber
and just leave your favorite Easter egg a
reference from the episode on the video or
your favorite moment because it was littered
wall to wall with crazy references but careful
for spoilers if you have not see the episode
yet will be talking about everything under
start at the beginning of the episode and
work our way through shot by shot.
Notice number these Easter eggs and moments
as we go along.
Starting with the episode title Rickdependence
spray which is a reference to the movie Independence
Day they're actually releasing the episode
a week after Americas July 4th, Independence
Day so we just had that big holiday.
But the plot of the episode was actually more
of a reference to this movie is an actual
real movie called killer sperm from outer
space.
You can make all the jokes about this season
being the horniest Rick and Morty season of
all like dragons was a big deal, but they're
taking almost all the season five episode
two next level, but Dan Harmon said that a
lot of the chud storyline during the episodes
are like the B storyline with all these horse
people in the sewers wound up making it into
the episode to purposefully highlight just
how ridiculous the overall plot was even when
they're getting hold in by the horses Morty
says this is out there even for us that the
writers referencing to the overall storyline
with the CHUDs the monster sperm.
Like this is almost too ridiculous of an episode
even for rick and Morty and Rick answers saying
should be quiet they can hear you referencing
the adult swim in the Turner networks executives
in real life that manage rick and Morty.
So the like a lot of the over the top jokes
were over the top on purpose highlighting
just how ridiculous the episode was in really
meta way they were also parodying a lot of
low budget 80s horror slasher sci-fi picks
to especially with this giant sperm plot,
but the cold open begins with Morty at Beth's
horse hospital trying to get Beth to hurry
up and finish work so that they can go see
their movie, they were referencing the black
widow movie which I she just got released
last week.
Because Beth says let's go see what the new
marvel movie the all over is which also plays
in the whole idea of all the Morty sperm during
the episode.
It almost felt like it was a requirement of
the episode that in every single scene at
least one of the characters at some point
makes a reference to judges they made fun
of marvel a couple times during the episode.
Like that Robert Downey jr joke that I put
the beginning of this video.
They reference marvel a couple times already
this season and episodes and I talked about
a little while ago, but the whole idea Dan
Harmon has been telling jokes about how marvel
has been stealing all the rick and Morty writers
the past couple of years.
Because several of them are now working on
big marvel phase 4 projects.
Like Michael Waldron is the showrunner on
the Loki series right now.
And he's writing Doctor Strange 2 multiverse
of madness movie whole premise of the Loki
show is kind of similar to the premise of
rick and Morty with many versions of the Loki
character from alternate universes.
The writer from pickle Rick in season three
is now.
The showrunner on the she hulk marvel series
and then Jeff Loveness who wrote the first
two episodes of rick and Morty season five
is now writing Ant-Man three quantumania.
So this feels like there a lot of marvel jokes
during season five is probably because of
that, then Morty lock size on the machine
that they use for artificial insemination
for basically milking male horses in being
the 14-year-old that he is, immediately volunteers
to work there is that he can use it to jerk
off as much as possible he's like a savant
when it comes to finding new ways to pleasure
himself.
They don't really give you an idea for where
this episode falls in the timeline.
Or if it's after the events of last week's
episode, you think that he be heartbroken
but he's a 14-year-old kid.
So touching himself comes as naturally as
breathing using a giant horse machine like
this isn't even the grossest thing that he's
done to get himself off.
That was so probably be the doll from raising
Gazorpazorp way back in season one to be fair,
they did take the joke about Morty and summer's
chud baby way further during this episode.
Like now is just alive in space out there
somewhere.
But Morty legit still has a living son Gazorpazorp
out in the world, he still alive until they
confirm is dead.
So this is not the first time for any of this
stuff for him is the first time that it's
gone this far off the rails spectacularly
Dan Harmon made a big Jumanji reference.
Like at the end of the first Jumanji movie
when everything goes completely off the rails
in a week goes by of him using that machine
he's drinking all that vitamin C that's a
reference to it supposedly boosting blood
flow in helping with erectile dysfunction
switches the writers joking that Morty's been
using the machine so much this junk is probably
about the fall off.
Which is a very Morty thing for him to do
when Rick explains his plan to create the
bioweapon to use against the Chuds it sort
of them setting up this weird B storyline
during the episode where they explained that
this race of chud horse people has been living
in the sewers for over 100 years in this been
is game of thrones level shadow war that the
American government has been waging with them
like this Cold War this been going on for
the last hundred years.
Like is a Dan Harmon kind of explain this
whole horse person storyline is a product
of how ridiculous the episode got like okay
we wanted to feel as ridiculous as possible.
If you not familiar with a reference chud
is actually an acronym it's based on a movie
see you HD which stands for cannibalistic
humanoid underground dwellers in that old
low budget slasher movie, the Chuds were former
humans who were mutated by radioactive toxic waste
And I think one of the funnier things in the
episode is, they never fully explain where
these chud horse people originated from.
Like how did they get created where it in
the first chud come from.
The way they set them up during the episode.
This backstory they created for them thing
to do a whole spinoff series with the CHUDs
the only thing they didn't do during the episode
that was kind of expecting that was have Beth
comment on the Chuds themselves, the horse
people, because she's so obsessed with horses.
It seemed kind of weird that she didn't find
them more interesting.
Or question their existence at all.
Again I think that was just part of the joke
like this isn't supposed to make sense is
supposed to be over the top ridiculous like
a no point in the episode do any people of any authority
Even the president question their existence.
They just keep referencing this shadow war
they been fighting against them for the last
hundred years a couple of you were also asking
if the CHUDs were meant to be a reference
to bojack Horseman.
Because he's kind of a horse person in the
rick and Morty people are friends with the
bojack Horseman people in real life.
They could have been referencing some bojack
stuff here, but I didn't hear anything specifically
about that they said the whole joke with Morty
doing everything in his power to not allow
Rick to find out what is been doing this is
this is a big problem when they were developing
the episode because they did like the idea
of everybody the audience and Morty knowing
something that Rick did not know but the way
they build the joke up you know it's going
to blow up in their face and it does, literally
this time.
Not really clear on what otherworldly forces
rick was referencing for the green fluid that
he's using looks like his portal gun fluid.
It all the giant monsters are meant to be
a reference to the movie killer sperm from
outer space the movie literally is just a
bunch of them from outer space in search of
new planets to colonize and they view the
earth as a giant egg waiting to be fertilized.
Which they reference again at the end of the
episode also with all the grand canyon vagina
references like a literally and metaphorically
trying to impregnate the earth.
I do love the look on rick's face here though
when Morty is so willing to let Rick take the blame
Like wait a minute what using the one to take
the blame for stuff like this is that he so
thrown off at the thought that maybe Morty
didn't do something wrong in this moment in
the car Rick claims they ran over their neighbor
Gene, no idea if he's dead, just because the
car runs over large bump that he says feels
like Gene.
He's the next-door neighbor from season three
who's trying to but in when Morty and Beth
were arguing pretty much all the neighbors
on their block are either dead or being chased
around in the never really address how they
deal with that going forward later in the episode
But I think kind of plays in with the theme
of the episode itself being so over the top
ridiculous like summer and Morty's baby is
still alive in outer space is like the new
star child, because of all the 2000 one space
odyssey references to say nothing of the giant
race of horse people living underground Rick
calls them space sperm.
Like I said a reference to that killer sperm
from outer space movie, summer and Beth both
wonder how big that means the space Dicks
are they sort of pay that off later with the
US Pres. to like man I wonder how big space
Dicks are, I think the funnier thing though
in this scene is when Rick says oh I've seen
them before they actually exist their real
thing in outer space.
So apparently they're just space sperm flying
around in the rick and Morty universe than
the US Pres. is back for the rest of the episode.
He calls for Rick's help again.
Just like season three episode 10 Keith David
was back for cameo scene during episode two
earlier this season.
But it was just for like a really brief seen
this time it's the whole episode is also other
trailer footage with him doing other stuff
with this giant turkey later in the season
so apparently the president is in a bunch
of episodes this year.
They take them back to the same secret tunnels
and bunker under the white house from season 3 episode 10
Although they don't reference any the special
rooms that are hidden down there Morty tells
rick that sometimes you have to wipe off your
problems and toss them in the trash, another
reference to jerking out there were a thousand
of those in almost every single scene.
Just because the whole premise of the episode.
Rick references cosmic DNA, yeti, chupacabra
in implies that both Stonehenge and ancient rome
All were sites related to sperm from outer
space.
Then like I said earlier the president references
this giant shadow war.
This conflict that the US has been having
with the CHUDs for the last hundred years
or so, and because they're trying to tie this
together with the whole Morty lie storyline
he's ready to blame the horse people for the
sperm insert an all out war, when he tells
Morty to blow the whistle toot toot and talk
about Rick that's just a joke about him being
abused by rick.
Like we all know rick cares about Morty and
the family, but a lot of the adventures that
they have do involve Morty being abused in
some way.
But to be fair a lot of the abuse that he
suffers is because of problems that he himself
creates especially in this week's episode
this her to playing into the idea of him lying
for the first half of the episode, Morty says
that America invented Apple pie and lasers,
he's only half lying there, because the first
working laser was created in America in the
1950s Apple pie was supposedly created in
England back during the 1300s.
Then when the president tells him he dodged
a personal drone strike that just an Obama
joke about Obama ordering a lot of drone strikes
during his time in office the whole professor
shaboobo character.
I think is meant to be a joke on Jeff Goldblum's
character from Independence Day he's being
played by one of the celebrity cameos in the
episode Kyle Mooney from SNL there were a
couple celebrity cameos, who apparently is
some sort of expert on sperm.
And a lot of his dialogue in the episode seems
like a parody of Jeff Goldblum's dialogue
in independence day when he was trying to
explain everything to the president to make
the whole joke about them going to the Grand
Canyon because they think of it as America's vagina
Like deep gash in the ground in the poster
that he pulls out, which seems like he just
bought it off a random shelf is America's
G Spot as if that's the rick and Morty universe
slogan for the Grand Canyon and you notice
when they set beth up for this big joke you
look at Jerry and he's the only other one
in the room here besides Beth doesn't immediately
get the reference the president tries to come
up with a whole bunch of sexualized names
for them like Orgazagoblins in the version
of the episode that I was watching was actually
sensors they kind of believed all the other
names.
So it wasn't able to hear all the names that
he listed off but then they call back to that
later in the episode when there out with the
Marines and nobody can agree on what they're
going to call them just referencing all the
different names the president listed off all
the names that he does come up with are meant
to be references to jerking off.
Then they keep playing up the Morty lie shooting
the giant sperm the minute they say they're
going to analyze the DNA, claiming that it
had a gun and observations goes completely
over the top like clearly everyone can see
that the sperm wasn't holding a gun.
It was even capable of holding a gun.
But the president just buys it on the spot
because they keep building up to this whole
reveal of Morty's confession later in the
episode.
The way they talk about is kind of misleadingly
the president says Morty would never lie,
so I'm going to believe everything he says
but the thing is that Morty lies all the time
on the show Morty then comes up with the plan
to nuke every last one of them before anyone
has a chance to discover his lie in this is
that whole slow burn joke with Jerry being
helpful by just getting everyone water during
the episode.
Like see him helping they set up the joke
with the sexy kickboxing with the sperm queen
which feels like a very specific reference
to a cheesy 80s sci-fi movie.
I couldn't find the actual movie, so if you
think you know what they're referencing with
this just right them blown the comments.
But they do pay off later when the Queens
like too bad you don't have any sexy kickboxer's
with you the whole joke with the trope of
Marines in action movies like this getting
killed off really quickly.
Like redshirt style the introduce Blazin the
ninja who seemed kind of like a G.I.
Joe reference.
Just like generic army ninja a reference but
the name Blazin the reference to fire the
bandanna you could think of him is like a
backdoor naruto reference in snake eyes would
typically cover his face overall he just like
in Imola gum of a bunch of different references
rolled into one make the joke about the difference
between catapults and Trebuchets because Morty
is the only one of the plane apparently who
doesn't realize the difference.
Trebuchets are kind of like catapults on steroids
the mechanisms they use for throwing things
is way different they throw much bigger things
way further the Marine makes a reference to
needing a fat P. Which is another Dick joke
that they can't settle on one of the presidents
names for the monsters he says are to call
them crispy creme's with a C instead of a
K. Which is also another reference to jerking
off the introduce the sticky character who
can sense that Morty is his father with his
junk vision or whatever they're calling this
version of heat vision his detection I think
the only reason why he looks different.
Like they gave him.
And I they made him a little bit pinker the
him two tails is that later when is a bunch
of them in the frame you can recognize who
he is the president references Jerry being
helpful again calling back to that earlier
joke.
He also apparently thinks that a lumberjack
in the morning and foxes at night want pants.
I'm not sure what the fox wearing pants is
meant to be a reference to but summer says
that the whole storyline with them using her
Egg to lure the monsters into a trap.
Which is another callback to the plot of the
movie about killer sperm.
They said the whole ending with Kathy Ireland
and Blazin's thong when he winds up killing
himself through incompetence in reveals that
he's wearing her thong because apparently
is super comfortable and he can also suck
himself off, trying to get Morty to help him
before he actually dies the sports illustrated
that he pulls out is also meant to be a version
of Kathy Ireland's real cover issue like this
is an actual real thing.
They changed the pose little bit but still
the yellow swimsuit and it's the 25th anniversary
issue and based on the Queens explainer later
in the episode.
The reason why the monsters are able to disable
all of Rick's weapons is because the queen
says they have Morty's knowledge.
Like he somehow passed them all of his genetic
memory, so they know everything that Morty
knows in the use it to counter all of Rick's
tricks the visual look of the Queen kind of
seems like they're going for a Krang Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles reference with the way
she has that tiny Mac that she's walking around
and she's the one who outs Morty's lie, claiming
that they're going to use him to create an
even bigger army conquer the earth.
I also love his reaction when rick calls him
out on it.
Like how was it images answers fantastic as
is crying on the ground.
As of all this trouble that he because was
somehow worth it Rick then makes a star wars
empire strikes back reference, calling himself
handjob solo.
Because he's frozen in a very Carbonite looking
storage device the Queen makes a reference
to all the times Morty jerked off before,
which is a lot talking about all the millions
of sperm who went to their graves inside dirty
socks and landing strips of toilet paper very
specific references I also love the way Rick
reacts here when they start milking Morty.
He rocks the prison like he's got some secret
escape plan, but then is like nope.
I just did this to get out of your eyeline
so that wouldn't get weirder than it already is
While this is happening when Rick says the
monster army heading to Vegas tracks, that's
just a joke about how debaucherous Vegas is
in then later when they cut to the president
and everyone partying in Vegas they make a
ton more similar references.
Like he's is that even though they have this
giant human egg to lure them here, Vegas by
itself should have been enough later when
they're spraying down the place with a bunch
of semen summer asks where did you get all
that the president just shrugs and says, it's
Vegas I also think of them partying here in
Vegas while this is happening even though
the world might end soon seems like another
independence day movie reference with all
the people partying despite the fact it's
the end of the world.
Then they said the whole joke with them, inadvertently
creating that baby with Morty and summer you
have to imagine that glasses Morty from the
citadel of ricks would pie be the only person
in the multiverse.
It would be happy about this what everybody
else finds out about what Morty did the president
implies that he did something just as bad
when he was 14.
Saying we were all 14 once.
But come on the also turn the baby joke into
a horse person chud joke.
When Rick sort of completes the sentence in
the chud soldier says wait, who told you.
Like he has his own baby and thinks that he's
just been outed they make a reference to thriller
movies with the countdown clock trope like
the clock only showed you the last couple
of seconds then Prof. Shaboobo probably yeets
himself off the building killing himself as
they just to continue underscoring how over
the top ridiculous the plot is Rick makes
more references to this ancient war this been
going on between humans and the Chuds, saying
that he always knew that Morty's horniness
would lead to an apocalyptic war between humans
and cannibalistic horse people you can see
that their chandelier is made of human skulls,
from the people they've eaten there also love
human schools around the king's throne as well
When they make a reference to Morty being
a scorpion in a Navajo fable.
That's actually a direct reference to the
real life fable of the scorpion and the frog
in that tale, the scorpion winds up stinging
the frog despite agreeing not to do that.
Saying that despite his intentions in their
agreement he can't change his nature.
But then Rick turns it into a big Robert Downey
jr Iron Man burn using him as an example that
people can change their nature, like a said
another big marvel joke big marvel burn during
the episode with the writer's taking a big
shot at all the trouble that Robert Downey
jr got into during the 90s.
Because of his addictions when he says that
Robert Downey jr was waking up in bushes and
his agent had to catch him with a butterfly
net she a reference to something that he did
in real life.
He went of going on a bender once in waking
up in a stranger's house.
Like he broke into someone's house while they
were high didn't know how he got there and
that one up getting arrested.
But that was many years before he ever became
Iron Man came into the MCU.
By the time he kind of turned his life around
then things really go off the rails with the
storyline when they set up the idea that Rick
apparently slept with the Chud Princess Poneta
and she's pregnant with his horse person baby.
And they just play it like it's not that big
a deal.
Rick slept with a planet.
He's also made references in last week's episode
sleeping with a bunch of alien queens all
the time so he does do stuff like this on
the regular then like a said Morty sort of
calls that out like this is out there even
for us.
Like this is ridiculous even for a Rick and
Morty episode.
I also love that when Princess Poneta it out
reveals her child with Rick, his reaction
is to admit that he has a substance abuse
problem.
Like he pry got super drunk one night when
on a bender and wound up sleeping with her.
But this whole subplot kind of goes full soap
opera, like isekai goes full game of thrones
telenovela they could turn this into its own
spinoff show and also of the little details
that the king adds to this to like a relationship
with Rick is bad.
Not just because it's a human in a horse person,
but because rick is an old man and she's young.
As if somehow, that's worse than them being
a bunch of horse people back in Vegas with
the president is deputizing everyone they
do this amazing Kevin joke.
He is a real life comedian performing in Vegas
the whole thing with the Nancy Reagan reference
I think is them just joking about how in real
life when Reagan was president.
His wife Nancy Reagan spent a lot of time
trying to sanitize television, movies and media
Like get rid of a lot of graphic stuff.
So the ideas them taking out all these monsters
is a metaphor for taking the episode from
NC-17 down to like a PG-13 rating when the
Chud kingdom shows up rallying at the castle
touches a reference to the tournament of kings
the Excalibur casino in Vegas in real life.
I've never been there, but it's an actual
thing the president makes another horse reference
when he calls rick the son of a mare, a female
horse also rick comes in writing on top of
poneta they right off the centuries long conflict
between their people.
So I don't know how soon they're going to
be bringing the Chuds back.
But this is their way of wrapping up the storyline
with the president was about to declare all
out war on them when Beth and summer ride
the monsters into the casino, the sign above
the door says loose slots, that's another
joke the sultan of swoon sign on the mirage
in the background is a Frank Sinatra reference.
Because he performed a lot in Vegas over his
lifetime then Summer implies that she's been
doing a whole lot a butt stuff on the DL,
but she's always been very open about being
a total freak in bed.
So this shouldn't be that surprising sticky
winds up killing the Queen, but then fertilizes
summer's egg anyway.
And then the president just in wipes his hands
of it firing it off into space.
Like well it's spaces problem now, because
were not killing it it's an election year,
which is another abortion joke like the president
doesn't want to piss off all the pro-life voters
And they pay out that whole Kathy Ireland
scene at the end is actually Christina Ricci
special guest star playing Kathy Ireland during
this the also use this to pay off the joke
about Morty lying at the beginning of the
episode.
Like you should always tell the truth even
it is going to hurt someone then they subvert
the whole trope of the moral message that
happened at the end of a lot of animated series
episodes when Rick calls it out saying no
no were not doing that.
I have my own epilogue to deal with because
the whole horse baby that he has with princess
poneta they telegraph a little bit where this
is going just because the way the rest of
the episode is wrapping up the whole joke
about Rick becoming an honest man giving up
his adventures starting a new family a new
horse family with pulling geta within instantly
take it back, saying the chuds are born fully
formed and we want to raise it.
So they kind of both white their hands of
it almost high five each other and then walk
away like peace out, see later.
No worries.
No harm, no foul the whole joke with the red
button shoutout saying that was easy is actually
Dan Harmon's voice sort of calling out how
it was super easy for the writers to write
themselves out of this corner this is their
way of avoiding having to deal with Rick's
chud son in future episodes.
But technically he still alive.
So will be funny if they made some verbal
references to all of these children.
Like even Morty and summer's child in space
within the post credit scene does pay off
the joke about Morty and Summer's baby it
turns into a big star child reference from
2001 space odyssey.
They even play some of the theme music from
the movie, thus spake Zarathustra it.
Like I said he still alive just floating around
they are in orbit.
So we'll see if they have some joke about
him in future episode.
But it seems like next week's episode five
is going to be another Rick and Jerry episode.
If you did spot any Easter eggs in this episode
that I didn't mention the video just right
them below in the comments.
My full Loki episode 6 finale video will post
Wednesday in my full Rick and Morty season
5 episode 5 video will post next Monday just
like normal everyone click here for that brand-new
Loki deleted scenes video and click here for
my full Loki episode 5 video.
Thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys tonight!